everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
episode three to nine of the askgaryvee
show perfect timing to have this
tremendous gentleman who is both athlete
and entrepreneur as the NBA season is
now upon us Chris Bosh is in the
building
you know and as a die-hard Knicks fan
and overlooking Madison Square Garden
you know I got to start transparent and
saying between the Raptors and the heat
not necessarily my favorite athlete of
all time because he dropped away too
many real games on our faces but I've
really admired Chris you know we haven't
we had one quick dinner I think at CES
where we were sitting on opposite sides
of table so we didn't really get a
chance to chop but I've been able to
really watch from far as I'm always
watching I think you've made a really
strong transition into life after
basketball but before before we go into
that actually this is a great question
because I know a ton of my listeners are
gonna have a lot of awareness of you so
I think the right first question is what
do you been up to man
that is such a good question you know
what yeah you know I've been um first of
all kind of had to rebound and in my
situation yes
you know how old are you right now I'm
35 yes so you know people people really
don't realize and I didn't realize
either really what happens to an athlete
after you're done playing you know we
kind of just disappear and go away and
maybe you'll see us on TV again but you
know that's when I think real life stars
for us yeah you know I have five
children you know yes awesome man and
then getting into the swing of things
into being a father
yep that's there more yep it's a being a
husband yeah it does like you know you
know as for me going hard and then
having children and even like evaluating
them if I doing too much or too little
or whether it's workout regimen or or
business like that that is a transition
in itself yeah it becomes a balance just
so all of a sudden you're like going to
daycare and like it's it's a thing yeah
yeah and you know school and and getting
them prepared and you know moving back
and forth and moving my family
Austin and and your situations a little
bit unique in the fact that you know
obviously because I follow sports enough
to know like it was a you know I I don't
think as many people will know this it
wasn't the easiest situation that led
you to not playing basketball no no no
it was a very dramatic well I mean um I
got blood clots I had a pulmonary
embolism back in 2014 no 15 that was
really bad I was in the hospital for
damn near two weeks that sucked
had to have surgery was obviously you
know I think um do you know something
was up oh it was slowly happening I mean
I know all the signs that look for now
but slowly I mean I first I thought it
was cramps and then a month later they
come back and then it became so
debilitating there's something wrong but
luckily you know made it through that
and then you know bounced back got back
in the plan um you know got back to my
form of playing the way where I was
happy and everything and then after that
my calf was sore I go to the doctor to
get a scan oh I got blood clots again
and then it became a problem because I
felt good you know I just everything
just was just stopped all of a sudden
one day and um you know yeah I wasn't I
was 33 got it 32 33 somewhere in there
yeah still like you had three four five
six
oh man six seven left in me I would
still be playing right now I think um
you know I wanted to play so I was 36
but I could have you know potentially
with the way you know things are going
in the league the first time somebody
said to you hey you may want to consider
not playing nobody ever said it really a
lot of people said it but you know SPO
is this true do I have this right SPO
was at the game when Hank Gathers passed
yeah you know I think that's a fact that
a lot of people don't know you're the
coach at the time you know I'm 43
I was outrageously
affected by Hank Gathers passing yeah I
was an eighth grade
super into the March Madness thing you
know Bo Kimble like it was you know it
was a big deal no internet back then
big big events really took over America
for a week yeah now Prince dies that
it's a half a day on Twitter you know
like rewriting stuff happens and it's a
half a day with the way our world works
now back then something big happens it
was a week two weeks in the news do you
feel did coach was coach affected by
that when he communicated with you
I was wondered about that I mean I know
coach a little bees a good great yeah
you know what it was you know I think
that was kind of everybody else's
thought process going through that and
saying oh wow this might this is dire
situation with me you know you don't
necessarily tell that person that right
yes you want them to kind of exercise
things and yeah get there by themselves
we never talked about it too much I mean
you know doctors like don't play yeah
you'll be fine sir like you've had your
life bro just really getting started
with this stuff and you're telling me
that you know that's kind of where the
disagreements came in with the
communication and our problem with
communication but that you know we got
over that and you know it was just my
stance was to continue to try and play
and that's what I did for about a year
and a half I know I watched um I tell
people this story I was watching so I
was in the next year a whole year went
by I said alright I know I'm gonna get
picked up this year I need to get in the
basketball I need to watch more
basketball cuz I kind of let it go last
year I was still working out but didn't
watch any games cuz you just needed that
break uh just mentally it was messin
with me I you know it hurts cuz you know
I was yeah it was right there and I felt
that we had a championship-caliber team
and then it just stops one day then I
saw Gordon Hayward dislocated his ankle
in the first five minutes I just turned
the TV on like all right here we go to
see this going on blue blue oh man I
said I right
right then and there I knew I wasn't
gonna play anymore really yeah I knew
and I had to I had to keep up with the
Jones I was gonna keep playing you
coming back yeah but you but I knew
right then he doesn't gonna happen no
more
yeah it's just like you know you know
that thing yeah I was there we were
strong and then boy it took all the wind
out myself no kidding yeah I was done
after that so then take me through the
next chapter so now you're now yourself
you know you're done you keep up the
facade a little bit because it's a hard
left and so you want to go through that
in what way yeah and then what you what
do you start thinking about next Shh man
what am i doing yeah you know that's not
easy I think I was already there at that
point already it took about two years I
want to say two years after I was done
playing it took me that long to kind of
come out the fog a little bit I
understand yeah you know and you know I
guess yeah that's what people call it
depression funny
my brother AJ was sitting right there
left Boehner we started this together
vaynermedia and then three years ago
three and a half years ago we started a
sports representation as a Spanish
sports we do football now and we have 20
guys 20 25 guys and our entire thesis
was you know off the field dynamics that
we could create but a lot of it was life
after football yeah these kids are first
of all football's crazy because a lot of
these guys are hovering yeah there's
real injuries in football there's real
stuff going on kids are you know the
first round picks out of the league
three years later for real for real so
yeah you know that's 25 that's 26 I mean
you know what do they do usually like
well me what's the next step in man most
kids really screw up they over spend
their money up front then they're done
they're 25 and they're like I mean this
is you know this is why we did it we're
like we think we can change it we've why
I watched he watched from afar that
agents and I don't even blame agents
it's not like I razz them I don't think
these are bad people they're in business
yeah agents are there and then when
you're not producing dollars it's their
responsibility to their company and
their family to go find things that do
and they're done and I we thought the
way to hack it was really
in these kids lives yeah through and
through and obviously our business
acumen all about other stuff
gave us leverage that they would
potentially believe us and now that
we're starting to do it a little bit
Walter pal Derek Morgan we're doing real
stuff for these gentlemen long after
football when they brought us no dollars
because we came in late in their
contracts now the reputations working
which is giving us leverage but going
back to you that's the thing like as a
kid even right now as a 43 year old male
who puts out content every day that
yells at people that says before and
you're young
I still think athletes that retire are
old like I wanna do their own garden
we're looking at the garden right there
last week the Hawks played a preseason
game and I've been telling people this
whole story it's like a running joke but
it's like okay about their Vince
Carter's so old how old is he like
everywhere he goes and it's just an S on
TV man you know how powerful TV is and
to your point now what's great I think
the best thing that's happened in the
culture of sports is that athletes have
become when I was growing up athletes
only wanted to maybe also or be rappers
if they weren't athletes yeah now they
want to be entrepreneurs - mhm and that
is completely I mean I've got five star
recruits when they're sixteen hitting me
up talking about life after basketball
football doesn't right so it is now cool
it is now legit and it also feeds a
little bit of their competitive spirit
yeah and it's you know there's a lot of
things that make me worried that
entrepreneurship has gotten cool because
I think a lot of people getting into it
that aren't entrepreneurs and unlike
basketball and rap they can't be exposed
real quick and they get into like their
own little deep you know depression over
time because they're not meant to be but
one thing I love about the rise of
entrepreneurship is it's absolutely I
believe something that is going to help
a ton of athletes in that transition
mm-hmm no absolutely so talk to me about
back to the first question what are you
up to now you get out of the fog yeah
good night assault man you know now you
know just trying to
good things out really what since I've
been in Japan I've been to Australia
media interest me you know I'm working
on a book for a 2020 release in the fall
for next year that's going great you
know I just started getting out trying
to make it have yeah yeah and so and so
how's that process been good it's good
yeah recording a little bit of
everything record and type in talking
interviewing you know it's like a whole
process but you know it's like a
chemistry that you build when did you
think you were gonna make the leak I
knew I was gonna make the league when I
was 17
you knew that the summer going into my
senior year yeah yeah prior to that
there was still kind of like yeah when
did you want actually it was great let's
go let's keep that on the shoppers yeah
when did you want to go into the leak
probably when I was like 6 or 7 it's
pretty early yeah very very early cuz
you know my dad was watching were you
Mavericks Naadam average were really bad
I'm aware yeah there are really really
bad you're like every other NBA fan
bandwagon yeah cuz MJ was on TV every
day you know so in the you know at first
I remember like thinking like who is
this guy you know in the same team
because every time I go over my
grandma's house in the summer they're
always playing and then everybody would
be around the TV watching it and my dad
would be doing the same thing so I say
yeah I won't do that this is the same
game that we play on the playground and
oh it's on TV and then after that I said
all right cool that's what I want to do
and it was always there but then family
that was really tall or athletic or
things of that nature
me oh yeah my dad is like 6-3 I mean I
have a couple tall huncles but nothing I
don't know where I came from yeah I'm
just a little little little tall and
when did you explode in height from 14
to 16 Thanks you went from what to what
I went from like 6 3 to 6 10 6 2 to 6 10
somewhere in there
so my freshman year I when I got there
as a freshman I was about 6 162 I left
about 611 prospect yeah so you know 14
to 16 is like oh I really want to be in
NBA and you know I was just practicing
really hard doing what I need to do and
then 17 18 a hike Kingwood at 19 I was
out of there so it happened fairly
quickly yeah it was like oh man you know
I'm a played NBA I'm gonna do all these
cool things and then I said it's time to
go I didn't you know I wasn't sure I was
ready but you know yeah it was crazy
like super crazy yeah it's actually the
one I've been telling a lot of people
lately and the flip speakers and
entrepreneurs and hustlers to get into
sports cards because it's getting really
really really hot and I did that as a
kid and the one time I got back into it
was your draft class oh really there's
so many of you guys I was like you got
some cars I had I mean we were AJ and I
were buying so we were opening up so
much FLIR basketball you're here there
was so much cuz we were like that was
just loaded yeah I mean it's an all-time
class yeah for sure it's pretty good how
did you how did how did your friendship
graph work with that class like when you
guys were obviously traveling around
together well for a couple weeks and for
the giraffe stuff but when did you first
make your connections with your but who
are your best friends in the league do
what if that meant this period overall
yeah but you know pretty much everybody
the whole championship team was an
amazing team everybody got along
everybody you know made great
connections Ronny Turiaf was great
friend of mine
Jerry Jack you're so funny I have a
Ronny Turiaf Jets Jersey how do you have
a Ronny Turiaf gesture because when he
came to the Knicks and he actually made
us like when he came to the Knicks
aren't
friend group got pumped because he was
bringing back a little bit of that 90s
Knicks he was being like a tough guy and
so for birthdays were always challenged
to give each other gifts that are like
unique so did you give me that AJ so AJ
got me a hottie Terry off Jets jersey
number 14 was it yeah so he knows about
wine oh yeah that's my guy yeah that's
my man Jerry Jack's my guy you know he's
my roommate at Georgia Tech and we
played together for a year nice cool
yeah you had a great I think he's I'm
not sure if he's still trying to play I
haven't talked to him in a minute
get a really nice career yeah but um
yeah I mean who was your best mentor
when you came to Toronto who like did
anybody kind of like
yeah it was a few people one was Michael
Curry
he was my vet you know coming in he was
like a no-nonsense dad type man and he
you know he taught me the value of you
know working hard and getting his shots
up Derrick Martin was the guy you know
he did a lot for me Sam Mitchell yeah we
had some fists that wasn't all at the
same time Michael Curry was only there
I'm afraid I'm in freshman yeah rookie
year Mike um
Derrick and Sam you know they pretty
much took me under their wing as soon as
they got there I want to say the next
year second dude a six year old fan no I
wasn't a bull I was a basketball fan got
it
just the Mavericks were just you know 16
and whatever that yeah so it was tough
kind of having you know some support for
the home team was happy for those guys
man I mean it was still so many people
of the managers and equipment guys
actually popcorn guys and the dudes in
the stands you know that I would talk to
every morning yep they were still there
and and I mean you know it's funny every
time I walked in it Chris could you
believe it no I can't not at all this is
crazy you know and then it's him you
know really you know get their moment
was amazing but you know I root for
those guys I root for Miami you identify
with the teams I played for
what about other sports do you grow up a
Cowboys fan yeah I'm a Cowboys fan yeah
yeah you know it's cool everybody's
always like oh you always get that all
the time yeah you know I'm look I'm from
Dallas I grew up during the glory years
you know and and you know it's a good
good franchise did all your homies from
back home razz you because of that NBA
Finals that must have been fun which
part nah they didn't they would if they
did we haven't spoken since really ya
know we didn't take it obviously I was
thinking my second Alice he loses a
really throne of course yeah terrible
but you've got those three or four
friends that are your boys boys who
might have actually grew up cheering for
the Mavericks since they were no no none
of us we were all Bama hurtin we were I
mean you know I wouldn't even call it
bandwagon you know I don't have a team
fair enough but like we don't have a way
it's a fin it's a variation of a wagon
it's an all-star wagon with a wagon with
no wheels here's my thing i I I got very
into tech in the 2000s and would go to
Silicon Valley a lot in 2006 seven eight
nine you know when I tell you because
I'm a big sports fan and this is the
time when it was all nerd land yeah they
barely cared about sports but when I
tell you there was not a person in San
Francisco that knew the Warriors played
there right like there wasn't a person
on earth I had never seen or anybody
wear a jersey of the Warriors yeah or
mention that word in the four to five
year period that I spent 12 15 times in
San Francisco yeah and now every kid in
Cleveland and Ohio and Dallas where's
Steph Curry's right shoes the Hat what
do you think about the notion of people
wrapping their own lack of self esteem
into something else
it's like Patriot fans right like a
bunch of them razz me on Monday night
and I was looking I'm like you did
nothing
do not infuse your team's success with
your actual success I mean you know it's
not much you can say you know hey I get
it
you know people want to feel good I mean
I remember when we got together
Miami and you know it was more Miami
fans we're like hey that's great then
the same guy will have a Cleveland
Jersey on four years later it's like
okay and the Jersey that's what you did
no I did not yeah you'd like the players
I liked players yeah that's what I did
me I could not have their Jersey nor
could I afford their stuff or their
shoes you know I had the posters I had
the posters on what I was about it you
know what I mean yeah yeah play video
games for sure you're stronger now no no
I'm retired and your pride in my prime I
was pretty good Madden was my game
Madden and call of duty at one point
time black ops 2 whoo I actually bought
part of the Minnesota franchise for Call
of Duty ok so that's my little step
towards ownership of the New York Jets
all right looks nice what what else what
else do you want to talk about what else
is on your mind man what's on your mind
bro you the guy you got the office by
the garden and everything my office is
not this nice my my the only reason that
my office is this nice is cuz I was
smart enough to realize this part of New
York was gonna blow up before most
people did we committed to this office
five years ago this was the only
building in this entire area we're
actually paying less rent in this
building than the building we left
that's like 80% like worse than this
because of the way the real estate
market worked out so this was another
kind of good bet what's on my mind
what's on my mind is tick tock yeah I
think tick tock is the place where
people that are trying to make it and
have no money I've been hearing about to
talk further past I really think it's a
real important place eSports we just
mentioned it it's very much on my mind
it's uh I'm just fascinated by the fact
that outside of NBA players and a little
bit of soccer players and a couple of
football players like eSports athletes
are more famous to the 15-year old today
yeah and every single baseball player
then 90% of the NFL then you know I mean
it forget about hockey I feel bad I'm
sure the average kid can name five
hockey players that are active in the
NHL so what about like content creation
and
you know all this stuff cuz I mean yeah
obviously so I mean that back to your
point of being interested in media and
content creation I mean I didn't stack
Aust of entry for any relevance in our
society I believe that if you're not
producing daily for Instagram Facebook
Twitter snapchat you know the you know
tick-tock LinkedIn YouTube that if you
don't have a podcast if you're not
thinking about a vlog that you are just
leaving an enormous amount of
opportunity on the table yeah now what
made you you know what made you see that
cuz I've you know watched you know past
videos and everything and you kind of
see you're very very passionate about I
was a super entrepreneur kid selling
these parts and all this I started
working in my dad's liquor store wanted
to build it up you know we were
immigrants my mom needed me my jet
jersey so I understand not being able to
for them and and I I just realized
ironically the story goes and it's true
I was playing mad in 94 in college my
friend came over he said you got to come
see this
it's September of 94 I go into a room
and a kid dials up to the Internet the
old cool couch dial-up [ __ ] and and I
was just like this is it nothing else to
say this is it like I believe this is
gonna be a big deal so you know right
like sounds like love at first sight
where you just know yeah I went all-in
learned launched an e-commerce wine site
in 1996 and the way I built my dad's
business for him was building a website
starting the email newsletter knowing
that Google was gonna be big Google
AdWords my real hit change in my career
happened when I started a youtube show
about wine in 2006 when I was 31 hmm
back to like no I mean I thought it was
a [ __ ] kid back to the beginning of
this conversation I push it on like I
think I'm a kid now like residence like
I think Vince has 30 years of
professional work to be done when he
retires like so I I really understand
people mmm that's what I've come to
learn I understand people
I like people a lot I'm empathetic which
is one of my wine brands called empathy
like I have that in me and when you have
empathy and you think about the other
person when you have compassion sympathy
empathy when you have those things
mixing you're actually thinking about
the other person as a matter fact if
you're great sale
you're actually thinking about the other
person I think the reason I've been
great at sales my whole life is I sell
things I believe in whether its wine
services my sneakers and then I try to
figure out why it's valuable for you and
if it's not I don't try to force it mmm
and so I've always been good at that
Twitter came I was right tumblr I mean I
was write a lot I'm write a lot but I'm
not guessing I already see it it's kind
of like the sports card thing right now
a lot of people
LeBron rookies have gone up from 1100 to
2300 in the last four months since I've
been talking about it it's not because
of me
it's just what was already happening
people like whoa you predicted I'm not
getting predicted you could just see
that people were moving I could see the
people that were flipping off whites and
Yeezys we're starting to post on
Instagram about sports cards yeah I kind
of those saying those same flip kits
yeah they're just trying to make money
and you know the sneaker games
impossible you got to wait in line to
get one pair you can't get volume but
like if you believe in Darren Fox or if
you believe right now a lot of my
friends in the sports card world really
believe in them Miami rookie yeah Tyler
here yes my man a lot of people are
really investing in him because he's the
13th pick right I think is right and
like and like you know just like you
could make real money I mean I told a
bunch of people a year ago to buy
giannis rookies cuz I thought he was
super underpriced I thought he was gonna
go and they went from 200 to 800 for a
lot of kids they're back down to 550 700
but like you know it has this market
it's on eBay and stock ex just dropped
it yes dog axis so stock FX is now
flipping it so now it's cool cuz that
always matters so you know I think
content matters I'm good at it because I
understand that I understand that people
are using tik-tok I don't make emotional
decisions and say well this is stupid
teenagers just doing drop songs like
it's not it's not how I see it I just I
don't think my opinion matters and I
think that's helped me tremendously
I don't impose my opinions on my
observations and I think that's a core
strength and I think that's why I've
seen a lot of things what was your first
hustle I tell you mine my first hustle I
was burning CDs off Napster yeah
that was a lot of that age where that
was a big one those entrepreneurs yeah
suckers - he didn't work it was
different though different was I haven't
seen those big ones though and I haven't
seen I don't know it was like it was
made by the same company but it was a
different were you getting sucker some
story in South Dallas yeah and I was
buying him wholesale and going back to
school and then but then I learned about
competition because one of my friends
were stealing from they ran me out of
business
somebody getting something for zero man
then I had a king size 25 cents ah Manny
Christ I hate to tell you my first
hustle because it's not something I'm
proud of but the first thing I did when
I moved to Edison New Jersey was I would
run around the neighborhood and I would
rip people's flowers out of their yard
and then ring the doorbell and sell it
back to them they didn't know that there
were those were their flowers or they
did but here they see this remarkably
cute you know six year old you know who
barely speaks English and they're like
Robin I mean first of all 98 percent of
people said no one of the reasons I
really want kids to work retail or sell
something within the first 10 to 15
years of their life is I think that most
people have a terrible relationship with
know they're scared to know they're
super scare to know and I think one of
the things that's great about working at
a restaurant or working at a retail
store or trying to sell something within
those first 10 15 years is you get real
comfortable with no yeah what was your
first retail job I've only worked for my
dad's liquor store gun as a kid and then
have run my own stuff so I've never
really worked everything up until 14
everything was baseball card shows where
I real I mean I still believe 95% of the
[ __ ] I do is based on what I learned in
the trenches of sports card shows yeah
100% yeah I had some crazy hustles I had
one all-time house so that has to do
with basketball the dollar stores popped
up in the 90s like 91 92 at first I know
everyone here is a youngster at first
youngsters
dollar stores weren't like
now where they have like new stuff and
it's made for the dollar store at first
it was some real [ __ ] like there was
warehouses the internet didn't exist yet
so you couldn't get rid of stuff on
Amazon or Ebay there were warehouses
filled with old stuff and here came the
dollar store and they're just selling
stuff like old stuff I remember I bought
a ton of Rambo toys that were 1984 toys
but I was buying them in 1992 because
they were just in a warehouse just old
stuff Zelda books like that was what I
was looking up but there's all sorts of
stuff anyway one day go to dollar store
and they have shack figures when [ __ ] up
Shack made huge noise I was in the
league but the same way he is now he was
commercial from the get for sure and
there was a shack toy line but what was
weird about this was this to just come
out like a year earlier but they were in
a dollar store so I looked at it so I
bought him all I bought all 25 that were
in the store I started walking down the
mall and with the Kmart to look for
cards and other collectibles and I
noticed there was shack figures in there
and they were $9.99 so I was like huh so
I bought I bought something at Kmart to
get the bag I went back into the court
food court
I put the shack figures I bought in
Kmart bag and I went back to Kmart and I
was like yo my grandma bought me these
toys I don't really want them I don't
have a receipt can I refund him and they
were like yeah and I'm like and I'm like
without a receipt and cash not store
credit again this is 1991
you know k mark didn't have their [ __ ]
together yet oh so then I went so I so
then I took five of them I returned them
I got 50 bucks back for what I just paid
five bucks for about 45 minutes earlier
then I went back to the dollar I'm still
on the ball fill some wall big shout out
you look like a [ __ ] but I went there
last summer I was crazy there's like
four stores open in the whole mall it's
finished but I went back to the dollar
store and said hey do you have any more
Shaq fingers and the guy working there
goes yeah when to back and brought out
cases I was like I'll take them all so I
bought them all
I bought then I came back two days later
they had more cases over the next and
over the next month and a half two
months I bought like four to five
hundred six hundred
act figures for a buck and kept
returning them to Kmart for 10 bucks
made like four or five g's real quick
stories he went to Kmart one day then it
was done and then like a month later
went to Kmart just my normal run looking
for x-men figures or sports cards there
was a hole clearance of Shaq fingers for
like $4.99 I'm so Gary won Kmart zero
yeah my first job was Blockbuster and my
real first love that was not I hated it
I mean they don't exist anymore they
were hot yeah it was hot before Netflix
like people mercy blah blah I said they
had it man I don't know what happened
what happened was that him by Netflix
for 40 million dollars I don't remember
the exact number the blockbuster past
they had a chance to they had a chance
to buy him and this is one of my
favorite stories in business history
blockbuster passed on buying Netflix for
a real real low number now they would
have bought the old Netflix which was
CDs in the mail who knows if Blockbuster
would have innovated to making an OTT so
it's not that 50 right which I'm sure
they had seven billion at this moment it
might be different right now and market
but Twitter - Twitter took a massive hit
today down 20% that's what's going on in
news community - one two nine three one
five seven three one is my text
community service that's another thing
I'm paying attention to a ton texting I
don't know if you've seen like Diddy
marshmallow a bunch of other people like
let's start numbers like that yeah it's
on the back of this app called community
okay and and I'm using it to one two
nine three one five seven three one on
the way here of five minutes before I
saw you I sent a text tip to 4,000
people in Miami hmm saying I got your
man Chris on the show anybody got any
questions
and so it's really an amazing platform
and you keep saying it on this and then
people listen yeah I'm saying it on this
one everybody's listening I'm hoping
more people sign up for it I'm doing a
bunch of like you know I'm giving away
access and first opportunities on that
platform because that platform I have a
direct relationship I'm not at the mercy
of Instagram instagrams algorithm has
clearly taken a turn over the last two
three weeks the same videos that would
get
a million views for me are now getting
six seven eight hundred then ones that
you see a five hundred thousand are now
getting to 83 20 so it's happened and
it's happening to a lot of people cuz
I've been bringing up for the last three
or four weeks and people are DMing me to
like what do I do I'm like you should
have done what I've been telling you to
do for two years build up your [ __ ]
tick-tock and your Twitter and start a
podcast and every no service
like people get 1-dimensional yeah what
do you got oh we're doing calls let's go
looks like a one and that's one of the
things I've been fascinated with trying
to you know figure out how to you know
be multi-dimensional especially in the
world today you know what I mean what's
what's like some things that you think
are great that really help you with you
know what I mean being multi dimension
boy I never your self-awareness I know
that I like to be helter-skelter the
reason that was a bad student is I like
a lot of actions so I don't know you
well enough but here would be my
question being multi-dimensional first
starts with self-awareness you just
might be actually better going super
deep on one thing or it might be awesome
for you to do with 4 to 5 things that
becomes a personality trait of like do
you like the chaos or do you like the
structure yeah so that's first second if
you like the chaos you want to start a
watch brand and have a podcast and do
the book and be on TNT and do your own
version on Instagram if you want do all
those things you have to be ok with
dropping some of the balls mmm of course
you know but like but you know it's a
really good thing I always you know
athletes get it a lot you know it's a
kind of one who's scared money doesn't
make money it's kind of like and you
know this you grew up and I don't know
how you were about this but there was a
lot of guys that don't want to take the
last shot mm-hmm there's a lot of people
right there's just a lot of guys that
don't want to and there's guys that do
and things of that nature
you know I think that uh I think that um
I think it's a self-awareness game and
you have to be okay with missing things
it's just like the last shot you okay
with missing it if you start five things
with a team you need to be okay with two
of them failing mmm I'm not scared of
anything failing except vaynermedia
because all those other things are side
dishes and inevitably some of them are
gonna fall and I'm okay with the booing
I actually use basketball a lot with
this I always find it fascinating that
people
scared to do things when their life
isn't over yet and I always make in the
analogy of if you're the home team in
basketball and the road team goes on a
Levin Oh run in the second quarter and
you call timeout your home team is
booing you the home crowd right they're
booing they're upset there's I mean it
depended on you they're booing in a lot
of places so I always tell people like
hey you need to you need to be okay with
that and wait to triple zero when it's
over right hmm that's the answer for
multi-dimensional stuff you know what's
up it's Gary Vaynerchuk and Chris Bosh
and we're calling you I'm feeling
phenomenal say what's up to Chris please
oh okay how's it going man awesome
what's your question well so my question
to Chris is you know obviously Gary
talked a lot about buying the Jets one
day and changing the culture
potentially changing the culture and I
guess my question to Chris is do you
think that it's really possible that he
could come in there with the same kind
of mentality he does the business and
has made pros and the organization
around it change and make it like turn
it into what he does with everything
else that he's touched up are you
talking about the chess yeah his main
question I think in the macro for
everybody's value taking me out of it a
little bit is do you believe ownership
has the ability to make an impact on
winning oh yeah absolutely I mean it
starts it starts from the top you know
um you know in my situation in
professional sports if you get somewhere
and you're supposed to win a
championship and the floors aren't clean
the locker rooms not clean you don't
know the owner at all you don't know
anything about the place that takes a
huge effect on the culture of things it
trickles all the way down
and you know it kind of sets this
precedent like nobody knows what's going
on so yeah it definitely can start from
the top I mean that's where it starts
because it takes usually you've seen you
know some gun-slinging owners come in
Anacin hey it's time to win yeah and it
just changes everybody's mentality
Daniel Snyder you know came in with that
it has not worked
Mark Cuban did it didn't work you know
and and by the way Martin you know just
cuz you are gold in something doesn't
necessarily mean you are in the next
thing like I have outrageous levels of
confidence that I'm gonna buy the Jets
and win Super Bowls but but that's
because I think I'm an operator like to
me a lot of times operators do well in
other operating situations I think if
you look at owners trust fund babies do
poorly because they've never operated
anything they were just in the lineage
of ownership for sure I think Michael
Jordan's done an atrocious job and you
see this a lot with athletes when they
go to coaching or ownership they really
struggle because they did it on their
back they never managed anything they
just were a superstar at their sport but
they don't know how to actually create a
culture or build something so Michael
Jordan's done an atrocious job that's
just fun for me to say so I think I
think if you look at the ownership
groups that have done well there has
been one or two there's been two ways
I've seen it work one this is an
individual that has operated other
things and they understand how to build
culture hire good people put them in a
position to succeed build relationships
from the popcorn guy to the superstar to
the GM to the fans or number two there
absolutely is some trust fund baby lucky
sperm Club ownerships that I've seen the
Giants it makes me sad to say that but
you see good families groom their
children in a way that makes them good
owners and I and you have seen that as
well not spoiled make them actually work
a little that kind of stuff so where
have you seen the best culture in your
professional career Chris I mean the one
I've been a part of you know Pat Riley
he's done a you know phenomenal job you
know and one of the things about setting
a culture for something not everybody is
going to agree it's not for everybody
but the structure is there from the
bottom to the top of what everybody's
expectations are what your job is
supposed to be and you know just really
the level that everybody's supposed to
meet every day so if we're here and it's
you know we're here to win a
championship though that has to go into
everything that we do the thought
process the things you wear the way you
speak to people the way you solve
problems you know and and I definitely
have to give credit to the heat those
guys do a tremendous job because it has
been the same and you know Miami fans
are a little funny because it's just
such a nice weather like they're funny
like watching you guys roll and them not
selling out playoff games along the way
that's just audacity and that's just
Miami they're a funny fanbase not to
razz Miami it's just it's a town that is
fun like the ownership but the heat is
phenomenal to me the fan base is a
little funny you guys didn't sell our
playoff games were you I don't yes i
watch it was loud you know loud but like
you know I your rebound yeah sure
good I believe is one of the all-time
most underrated plays in sports history
because of the impact it has on the
enormous passion people have debating
the goat when it comes to basketball
I mean in its basic form for the non
basketball fans that are listening Chris
gets a rebound in an NBA Finals kicks it
out to Ray Allen that basically I mean
just very black-and-white the series
ends if he doesn't look I believe you
know I was a little passive with
basketball but LeBron I think took that
shot like that means he would have
missed that shot they would have lost
that series that's a big [ __ ] play
yeah kind of you know things happen a
little differently do people Martin take
so much brother
do people sorry I'm
I must radio I want to get into a point
I had to put them off I didn't need him
chop it in Chris you do to a lot of like
I'm a hardcore sports fan I watched
every play of a New York Jets game since
1982 so I know every single play
obviously this is a Finals game it's a
huge play I feel like if I was a Heat
fan and I came across you at an airport
I would be over-the-top compelled I
wouldn't want to bother you but I would
have to find some way to be like bro
that rebound means everything to me like
do you get you get a lot of love or back
to my point that this is one of the
great underrated plays in NBA history is
it just that's the way life is it kind
of it's a sneaky little part of it most
people don't go to that extra layer of
thinking yeah actually happen I mean you
know I think it kind of it kind of goes
both ways people you know see it and
they'll you know tell me about it and
then you know you have all I wanted to
ever do is make a big play for sure I
mean you know as a kid growing up you
know probably play those games and stuff
like that the ironic part for me was
that it was really a exercise for me
because I didn't score in that game no
game six I did it was just a struggle
for me offensively in that whole series
you were just off it was yeah they
defense the best team I can world I know
and again it you know the way they were
defending us what's they pretty much
LeBron and Dwayne had to carry it um
they stuck to me yep didn't really
rotate much and it was working I think
so
yeah man Tim was pretty much matched up
the whole series but seemed like the way
they were doing phenomenal basketball
clearly and you know great coach I'm
sure but you know at the time it was
just kind of it was a very tough series
and everything happened so fast we were
winning and we were in control of that
game you know with two minutes left we
get into a situation where we
got brown on Tony Parker that was our
game plan for the late game situations
all right we've executed it perfectly
Tony hits that step-back three we turn
it over a couple times
we're down yeah five points it just
happens really quick the only thing that
kept me in it was that my wife you know
when you're about to lose a big game you
look around at your family for sympathy
you know it's just like that look when
it's like ah damn but I looked at her
and she wasn't looking at me you know
she just stood up and start clapping and
you know it's kind of like a shell shock
when you go to the bench it's kind of
like a holy [ __ ]
oh no and we were just kind of I was
looking at everybody else and say yeah
this is not a good situation I looked at
my wife and she was she just stood up
and start clapping was like I don't know
what the hell she was looking at and so
that snapped me back into it and you
know we were able to make the place to
extend the game and extend a series that
rebound just happened because basketball
yeah playing basket but it's [ __ ]
huge yeah well I mean you know I was
able to watch the trajectory at all you
know what I mean so back you know back
some time ago one of my good friends
told me hey or a great player told me if
you want to get a rebound you get there
before the ball gets there right so in
that situation I could watch you
practice watching the ball hit you know
go and you just know where it goes after
a while I was able to kind of watch it
the whole way yeah and you know first
person was right
took a person singing yeah and in my
mind it happened there is like slow
motion animation in real time is still
just a second yeah it still does not
seen that way in my mind to me like our
watches like okay I I think I genuinely
think that that plays really underrated
you know I don't even want I like the
fact that it's kind of under there kind
of hey hanging right there in plain
sight um you know because you just hope
that you can make those type of plays
that people will remember you know I
remember one Jordan
hit autosize Max and Steve Kerr you know
Hakeem Olajuwon I just think that play
needs to be branded more I really really
genuinely think like that needs to be
more known as like the rebound it is
that big I really do think it's that big
and honestly and I listen I hate Michael
Jordan so I've spent my entire last 15
years hoping and wishing and rooting for
LeBron to do whatever he needs to do
it's crazy
my number one grateful thing towards you
is that rebound because without it that
game would have been over and the series
would have been over and probably have
made some changes with the team I mean
we were fully aware we were fully aware
of what we were up against is this you
know but I always tell people I'll get
mad when you know somebody said well the
game's over I get so mad you know
because it's like though the game is
never over until you say like Triple C
you know what I mean like I will leave
don't leave that was really first of all
especially in my two favorite sports
basketball football funny like that like
there's just something to actually all
that's absolutely right that's
absolutely don't leave man and so any
other people you know even you have to
stick with things even you know
sometimes you'll give up on yourself or
something like that when you're right on
the cusp what even was hottest you were
in your career
like when I asked you that question what
what stretch of time what period like
what two weeks I've always fascinated
like but you know it's funny I've been
during the majority of your career I was
quite passive with basketball in
comparison Knicks went into a coma and
my career took off and I was working
till 11 p.m. to him every weekday so
unlike football where Sunday I could
make the commitment it was hard for me
to get all in but you know but in my
childhood I was super in I actually back
to the Spurs I just remember David
Robinson would have pockets where he
would just go lightning hot like it was
just really interesting to watch some
people go like when I asked you that
question do you think of like year three
in Toronto just like this two weeks
where you were just you know 30 and 20
like it was there it was there ever a
period that you actually remember being
ultra hot for like a week or two or a
month nothing out of the ordinary maybe
you know maybe it was a couple times up
when a month
like I couldn't miss but yeah you know
you forget those pretty quickly you know
cuz the keepers never know yeah you
remember I remember like they're the big
stuff you know what I mean after wise
like alright I was hot for a week you
know I still didn't get the accolades so
you know I didn't get those awards that
normally come with yes yeah so that made
me kind of say I this really doesn't
mean anything about one of my favorite
cultural moments ever that concert you
guys put on when you guys all sign that
it's pretty sweet it was you when's the
last time you saw it like on the
internet or on TV by accent oh yeah oh
you know because we I mean you know we
were having fun you were you were real
happy oh yeah I mean I remember I
remember that part the most I'm like man
he's real it's warm right now he's
starting to get chilly I like the too
and you know like brisk in Toronto Falls
but this is something different I'm some
real [ __ ] do you view that chapter you
guys like it you know back to the four
five six like it really like I remember
being like oh man this would be boring
for a long time you know incredible
dynasty going at the same time yeah and
that Mavericks team got hot at the right
you know yeah anyway like I mean this is
a really challenging question and I'm
not looking to make it challenging I'm
just genuinely curious I'm really I'm
curious do you view that chapter as a
success or is there a level of
disappointment because you thought you
could have done more not success says I
can see it either way I really genuinely
did yeah yeah well I mean you know
people have to so the whole story behind
that was right you know we signed we're
there the decision is the night before
we're having crazy parties as Miami you
know what I mean I had never seen that
many cameras around our hotel we were in
the W I mean see if cameras hundreds and
hundreds of cameras I've never we
haven't even played a game so the next
day you know I know basketball all right
we're gonna do the press conference
we're gonna go through the whole thing
we hold up the jerseys boom we gonna get
out of here you know twelve o'clock
comes noon
nothing to one o'clock two o'clock three
o'clock nobody's hitting us back we're
just sitting in the hotel room just
sitting here three of you no no me and
my family I hadn't slept in 24 hours I
was just up so they eventually called us
I hate come down to the arena about five
or six o'clock we pull up to the arena
is thousands and thousands of people
they got jerseys printed already posters
everywhere is I mean it was overwhelming
and then so then we got in there
they said all right this is what's going
on and they explained everything to us
and I that's so cool this is crazy and
you know they had to build up there
because there was a concert there the
next day I just found this out so
everybody thought we like we didn't you
know honest I wasn't even worried about
that it was just an image in my head of
like the three of you yeah you guys were
just like that must have just been
amazing
I love 25,000 people there with no
basketball and you're and you're in your
20s yeah and optimism is attractive to
me and you guys were like we're gonna
win 87 times you saw what happened when
joining them got together what about us
you know it's like you know you know we
were just it was kind of you know being
young and naive at that time too cuz
everybody was happy we weren't worried
about watching what we say we didn't
know that things could get out as
quickly as they can see at that point in
your career like when did it start
seeping into your head like a year
before it happened during that season
late for 2010 yeah like what like you
know you're a human like yeah like like
I know kit you I know you were a
professional focused on the season at
hand yeah you're [ __ ] human you might
have thought about I got kids like the
kids that were talking to right now for
next NFL Draft who are worried about
their second contract for four or five
years from now and I think that's smart
not stupid yeah so I'm just actually
curious for you when did free agency and
how that was gonna play out play out in
your mind it kind of really start
playing into a 2008 two years yeah two
years before not that we were not that I
was obsessing we had signed the deal um
the three with the four-year option so
you know that was getting closer
and once that started getting closer it
became this you don't think so people
would ask you about they force it in
your head you know so they make you
think about and you know lead you the
people lead you and then yeah well I was
human and I didn't put two and two
together and as far as like having the
foresight to look at the class didn't
you see who all's gonna be available in
2010 all right yeah it's gonna be you
know a [ __ ] show and 2010 I got to get
ready for it but every single day it was
you know questions and everything but I
had eventually I had to get to the point
where I'm back to lead my team so I
couldn't really worry about that stuff
because they wanted me to leave I had to
deal with all that stuff so that wasn't
that fun yeah I mean you know it kind of
sucked in you know just making a
decision to play on the big stage I
wanted to play on the big stage it's
always my favorite question people
always told me to run it was either
Toronto or Miami
yeah and so that's why it's kind of
funny going to Miami it was kind of
telling full-circle your agent like the
process the interviews beforehand like
you feel like yeah yeah yeah it was four
or five for me the whole time and you
know people were telling me yeah you're
not gonna make it to five so you know
just be ready
Toronto you're going to Toronto you
still don't believe him you still have
to go through the process of getting
drafted and everything and you know it
worked out what do you think about all
those baggy suits they were terrible I
looked at my suit I thought I was so
cool oh yeah there with the spikes and
crystals and wore shorts thanks for
being on the show man I appreciate
thanks for having me yeah real pleasure
uh this was episode 369 was it
329 all right we got 40 more to go
together two one two nine three one five
seven three one hit it thank you thanks
Chris thank you
that was fine